Merry Christmas Eve Alex so he's still
alive must mean you haven't told Mom
you're pregnant yet we want to be
careful to do it right now you're being
careful
I can more look at me oh this is going
gray oh my God she is I was just gasping
at the haircut apparently this is what
happens when I feel stressed now well
we're telling them today okay that way
if Mom freaks she'll have 10 days in
Bermuda to calm down okay then go now
she's never in a better mood than on
Christmas Eve wait is this a good way to
tell her we hang a stocking for Grandma
Claire and when she goes I'm not a
grandma we go tell that to Haley and
my's baby
promise me you won't homeschool this kid
mom what are you doing oh Christmas
cards are just clutter wait you can't
throw away Uncle Cam's card you know how
sensitive he gets about his piano
placement remember that one year where
his card was slightly behind the one
from our old babysitter
um I believe he spoke the Charming
phrase and who is this [ __ ] well
Christmas is at Grandpa's this year so
cam will never see it
check out the sledding polar bear paper
can't look at that and not be in a good
mood huh yeah I am so sick of that stuff
I ordered five rolls from some kid for a
school drive he shows up with 50. his
fault and he bursts into tears like it's
on me that he can't count I was six mom
okay one of my teeth is loose I am
begging you to tell them that's what
this is I'm coming down the chimney as
Santa delighting Joe and Cal mom will
see how good he is with kids and then be
super chill with us being pregnant
oh
I'm stuck
okay everybody come on picture time in
front of the tree let's go oh God just
be quiet there you are okay where's
Dylan oh Mom oh we need somebody to take
the picture
harsh
what was that don't we always have the
fire on no I'm sure we do last year we
used it to finish cooking Claire's
turkey pieces Jay go turn it on wait
wait wait wait every Everybody 12 and
under out what
honey uh
what's going on
Dylan's stuck in the chimney
why he's dressed up as Santa he was
going to hand presents out to the kids
oh and tell them now I want to be with
you
tell us what nothing it can wait no he
can't please organs are shutting down
okay fine I
we have an announcement
Dylan and I are having a baby
are they smiling you're pregnant
yes
we're really happy about it
why wouldn't you be
wow
um
it's it's a lot to process it once and
okay
baby unbelievable
congratulations
you handled it a lot better than I did
back in the day oh
outside on the inside I'm you can
somebody save my life oh oh okay I'll
grab a foot yep
just in there I've only had some kind of
award-winning placenta-based lubricant
fine
hair Dylan use a little bit of this I
can't believe a little Dylan is gonna
pop out of you what would that even look
like
[Applause]
everybody come on in for the picture
this is all going to work out right no
right here definitely yeah hang on let
me get my elbows ready
okay everybody smile say baby
[Applause]
baby
[Music]